- [Pulkit] We really believe
that dexterous manipulation
is going to be the future
in robotics.
What can robots do today very well,
is they can move around
and they can pick up objects.
But just imagine for a moment,
what do you do you do in your house
or what happens in assembly?
You might pick up a screwdriver,
use it to screw in a screw.
You might pick up a knife,
use it to peel a vegetable or cut it.
What these things involve
is picking an object,
but then making sure
that the blade of the
knife faces the vegetable.
This task is what we
call is reorientation.
If I take an object in one pose,
I try to rotate it into
a different target pose.
Now, this involves my fingers
to make and break contact with the object,
which makes it quite challenging.
And also, the fact that
I have my fingers move
in coordination with each other.
Now, what we present today
is a versatile dexterous
manipulation system,
which can reorient many complex shapes,
just with one depth camera.
And everything is now open-source.
So it turns out, currently,
robots could pick up objects
and that is why you're seeing
a lot of deployment happening
in logistics and in warehousing.
But what robots couldn't
do before was to use tools.
And one of the key enablers
is for the system to reorient objects.
So as you see now, this robot
is reorienting the object.
It has four fingers which are moving
to get the object in the right shape.
- [Tao] It performs best when
we do it on the train objects,
and it has some decent
generalization capabilities,
so it can work to some extent
on some unknown objects.
And of course there's a
big room for improvement.
So we are still working on
improving the generalization
aspects of this controller.
- [Pulkit] So what would
it take for someone
to get this up and running?
How much time do you think it'll take?
- So amount of time it
takes to build the hardware,
which takes a few hours.
And then the second part
is setting up the software
and we provide the docker image
so people can just download
and then run the code directory.
So in the upfront software side,
it should be even less than one hour. This
- Is our effort towards making robots
or robotics being more democratized,
being more open source.
- We train everything in simulation and
because in simulation
we can get tons of data
and so we can really address
these challenging issues.
And eventually we transfer this controller
from the simulation to the real world.
We open source the code
and also pre-train model
and also the CAD model
so everyone can replicate our results.
And this is very important
to promote the dexus
manipulation research.
And another thing that's very
different from what we did to
what OpenAI did is we
actually in our setup
or the hand is facing downward.
And in this case, the
graph really matters.
- My hand is protecting against gravity.
But just imagine how
do you use your knife?
How do you use screwdrivers?
Your hand is always facing on the top.
So now when I'm reorienting
this object, the problem is
that if I make one small mistake,
the object can drop down.
And most importantly, we don't
have to assume a fixed set
of objects, which means that
if you have a new object,
if you're in a household in your factory,
you get something new, you don't have
to go and retrain the system.
You can use our system to
hopefully still be able
to reorient the object.
We can think of even more things
where the technology might
have potential applications.
What about prosthetics style?
- If a robot can use
different kind of tools,
then it can really help the
people with disabilities
to use those tools to do daily tasks.
- One of the things which
has restricted robotics
for quite some time is if
you have a new task, you have
to build a new controller.
It requires teams of people and weeks
or months, even half a year of time
to design a controller for that task.
And one thing with Tao
and other people in the
lab we have been trying
to develop is a paradigm
where we can train controllers very easily
with very less human effort.
The system is completely centurial,
but how, you know, we know
that once things are centurial,
they end up having some issues
because simulation is
always a model of reality
and not reality per se.
- So the way we do centurial is
that we train a neural network
controller in the simulation
and this simulation is a digital twin
of the real world system.
And after we train the
controller, we just transfer it
to the real system and
the in a zero short way.
In terms of the simulation
to the real world gap,
there are mainly two gaps.
So one is the perception gap.
The images from the camera looks different
when it's in the simulation and
when it's in the real world.
- And that is perhaps because
the rendering is not as good.
- The rendering in the real
world is much more noisy.
And in the simulation the
rendering is very clean.
And another gap is dynamics.
This motors behaves actually different
when these real motors and
also the simulated motors.
And while we get reasonable
centurial transfer performance,
there's still some room for improvement.
- So of course we have not
solved the reorientation problem.
There are many limitations
there still exist
that the system is not as
precise as we want it to be.
Sometimes it also drops
objects, unfortunately.
The other thing we are really
excited about is the future
of Dexter hands.
You know, for a long time
people have been developing many
different kinds of Dexter hands,
but they did not exist in
algorithm which could perform
complex manipulation
such as reorientation.
But now that we have the
algorithm, we think this space
of Dexter's hands is
going to heat up again
and which might change the
landscape of what people think
robots are able to do today
versus what they can do
very shortly in the future.
And that thing really is tool use, right?
Not just picking objects, but using them.
The future is truly exciting.
The future is going to belong
to Dexter manipulation.
And what we're giving you today is just
a preview into the future.
So stay tuned and we'll be back.